[Music]
20:18 is coming to a close which means
it's time to make some predictions about
trends and technology for 2019 will
mostly be looking at the web but I also
want to talk about important things
going on in native development social
media and finance at the end of the day
app development is all about building
products that make people happy and
there's some really exciting emerging
technologies that I can't wait to
explore on this channel in 2019 if
you're new here like and subscribe and
you can find a full write-up with this
video on medium prediction number one is
that web components will finally go
mainstream the funny thing is that I
could have made this prediction in 2012
and it would have been completely wrong
they've taken too long to standardize
and find browser support and have never
developed the refika systems like you
see and react angular and view we
desperately need web components because
we have really smart people working on
these frameworks that are duplicating
each other's work over and over again
like do we need a dozen different
libraries wrapping bootstrap or material
just to work in a specific framework and
how many times do we need to reinvent a
Pickers or tooltips or other common UI
elements with web components we can
build a really badass date picker once
and then use it in every single
framework or anything that uses HTML web
components will grow in 2019 for two
reasons first we have almost universal
native browser support especially with
edge movie to chromium but more
importantly we now have the tools to
build web components at scale via
angular elements lit elements tensile
state j/s and others I'm not just saying
this I'm building my next product fire
ship IO with web components and even
though it's a static site it can deliver
an experience as engaging as a single
page application and it's faster and
more flexible but frameworks are going
anywhere and that brings me to
prediction number two that angular
reactant view will continue to grow in
2019
it's pretty clear that these are the big
three choices for front-end development
they all solve similar problems but do
it in different ways that just seemed to
work well for different types of people
personally I have a love-hate
relationship with all three of them in
2019 I predict react will get hooks
which allow you to write components
without a clasp this means you can
manage state directly in a function
which fits into the ergonomics of react
angular will get the new IV engine which
will make it smaller faster and easier
to debug and bjs will get version 3
which is being completely rewritten a
typed script and speaking of typescript
that brings me on to prediction number
three which is typescript will continue
to grow even people from the react
community seem to be migrating over to
typescript over the alternative flow
which is sponsored by Facebook that
brings me to prediction for another
Facebook sponsored project graph QL
graph QL is also going to grow
significantly in 2019 but it's
definitely not going to replace rest as
you might hear from certain people out
there if you have multiple client-side
apps that need to query the same
back-end for different slices of data
graph QL can be an extremely beneficial
tool and far superior to rest in many
ways but there are a bunch of trade-offs
and it might not be right for every
project so make sure to do your research
before just jumping on the hype train
now let's move on to firebase as a gde I
know some really awesome stuff in the
pipeline that's not public yet all I can
say is that firebase is going to
continue its pattern of releasing really
awesome features that you won't find on
any other cloud a few things that have
been hinted publicly though with
firestore in particular would be
automatic backups proof sub collection
queries and geolocation queries and
we're also likely to see additional
runtimes for cloud functions like go
Kotlin swift and others now let's look
at another huge trend that's probably
the most important one of all which is
webassembly
now I don't think webassembly is going
to take over in 2019 or anything like
that but I do think it's at the point
where you should start learning it it's
already being used in production and
apps like AutoCAD and figma but it's
very intimidating to the average
JavaScript developer myself included
that's why in 2019 I plan on releasing
some videos about thrust which is a
programming language developed by
Mozilla that I think offers the best
path to getting started with web
assembly and just like graph QL and rest
waz 'ln is not going to replace
javascript but it is something that
gives us additional options as
developers and entrepreneurs that we
should explore let's move on to
prediction number seven water when I
first saw flutter it didn't really make
any sense to me why would Google care so
much about a cross-platform tool for
developing iOS and Android apps when
they're already maintaining the Android
platform but it turns out flutter is not
about iOS or Android it's about Google's
next-generation operating system fuschia
nobody knows exactly what Google's doing
with fuschia but it's rumored to replace
Android and run pretty much everything
under the Google umbrella by the early
2020s
and how our developer is going to
develop these apps on fuschia they're
going to use the flutter so if you learn
flutter today you'll be positioned to
develop native apps on virtually any
platform in the near future and it
actually delivers a great developer
experience so expect some videos on that
and 2019 as well
prediction number eight is the continued
adoption of service
now AWS already dominates the cloud but
they released a game changer for server
list just a couple weeks ago it's called
the custom runtime api and it allows you
to build a service architecture with any
back-end that means any programming
language any libraries that you need can
be available in that runtime without a
docker container this solves one of the
biggest limitations with functions as a
service which is not being able to
control the runtime and also potentially
solves vendor lock-in if other clouds
adopt similar api's
computing resources are just like the
electricity that comes out of your wall
it just needs to be there to run your
gadgets or run your code in this case
serverless won't replace docker
containers in 2019 but we are moving in
a direction we're running code in any
language is as simple as plugging
something into a wall but there's an
alternate universe here and that's
prediction number nine which is the
decentralization of computing the
mainstream hype with Bitcoin is
obviously over and it's not going to go
to three hundred thousand dollars or
anything like that
but the underlying technology gives us
the potential to build decentralized
apps that are not only stable but
incentivized for the user like YouTube
pays me a small amount of advertising
revenue for these videos but imagine a
decentralized platform where I could
earn advertising revenue independently
and everybody else to share the earnings
of the compute resources required this
might just be a pipe dream but I think
it'll only take one or two successful
decentralized apps to really open the
floodgates to a full wave of new
technology and that brings me to
prediction number 10 which is that
machine learning will be implemented in
apps by developers that have no
experience with machine learning this is
primarily made possible by new services
from AWS GCP and Azure and the
implementation of new computing
resources like TP use that can eat
through data at a staggering rate we're
approaching a world where ml will be a
part of basically every technology
experience that we have everything from
IOT to our washing machines to our
phones to our kids toys so no matter
what you're working on it's probably a
good idea to think about how much teen
learning integrates into it the AI
Godhead will not emerge in 2019 but you
definitely don't want to make it mad so
now let's move on to the bonus round
where we look at some trends outside of
the development world let's start with
social media Facebook has had more
scandals this year than I can even count
I stopped using the platform many years
ago but I think the argument to do so in
2019 is stronger than ever but to
counter my own point Instagram is still
growing and popular and youth culture so
Facebook the company will be just fine
and they owe a lot of that success to
their decision to steal a bunch of
features from snapchat which is kind of
sad for snapchat because it is looking
like a dying platform in 2019 and their
users are going to the platform that
stole their feature is Instagram but
that's just life I guess and speaking of
dying platforms Twitter once again looks
like it's dying as it does every year
but I think it'll see its worst user
declines in 2019 and while I use Twitter
and enjoy it I think it's well past its
golden age one thing that is becoming
clear is the importance of video content
I'm not just saying that because I make
youtube videos but the actual numbers
support it and we have social video
platforms like tic toc growing like
crazy so if you're building an app or
marketing an app you should definitely
think about how video plays into that
strategy
and the last thing to consider is the
stock market and specifically tech
stocks have been way down the last few
months
stocks are usually a leading indicator
of other things to come so just
something to keep in mind I'm gonna go
ahead and wrap things up there thanks
for watching and I'll see you in 2019